thank you to curiositystream and nebula
for sponsoring this video
check out the link in the description
below this is me
in 2012 during my fourth year studying
physics at oxford
in your fourth year you chose two major
options that defined your master's
degree
i chose atmospheric physics which is
what i ended up doing for my phd
and theoretical physics which was for
the most part a course on quantum field
theory
during this year my mental health
collapsed as i've talked about elsewhere
and after doing really very well in my
third year
i did abysmally in my fourth year
and the quantum field theory in
particular just never really entered
my brain i never really understood the
subject and ever since
it's been like an albatross around my
neck the subject has always represented
to me
my failure for whatever reason in that
fourth year
this is the textbook that we used in the
course quantum field theory in a
nutshell by the cryptically named
a z the oxford theoretical physics major
option was basically the first
section of this book but this one didn't
come from a library
this is my personal copy just after
finishing the masters i bought myself
this copy because i told myself that i
would come back to it i was going to go
back and beat this subject
but unfortunately this textbook has just
kind of sat on the shelf like this giant
black
monolith judging me but no more this is
the month that i
am going to conquer my everest i'm gonna
teach myself
quantum field theory again that was
three months ago as you may have guessed
a couple of things happened along the
way
before going any further i should
probably briefly explain what quantum
field theory
is basically it's a way of describing
the universe
specifically how subatomic particles
like electrons and photons
interact with one another to produce
phenomena like charges attracting or
repelling each other this video isn't
going to go into any
great depth on how exactly that works
but i'll leave some resources in the
description if you're interested
suffice to say qft is like an upgraded
version
of quantum mechanics with significantly
more complicated maths
now it's been nearly 10 years since i
did my masters and in that time i
haven't really done
any quantum mechanics so i feel like
jumping straight into the quantum field
theory the advanced version
is probably a bad idea so that's why i
finally bought myself a copy of this
this
is paul dirac's classic textbooks
principles of quantum mechanics
i use this a little bit in my
undergraduate but i never really
appreciated it
and it's such a classic text that i
thought i'd buy myself a copy
so what i'm going to do for the first
couple of days is actually not really
touch the z i'm actually going to mostly
focus
on the dirac and just make sure that my
principles the fundamentals of quantum
mechanics are
up to scratch another thing i'm going to
do in this experiment though is not just
rely on
pen and paper which is how i did things
when i was at university
i'm going to try and incorporate some
pen and paper stuff but also
mostly take notes in notion which is my
preferred way of
living my life at this point it's
software that i always recommend
students to use but i've never actually
used it when trying to teach myself
something so this should be an
interesting experience
jasmine was bitterly complaining that i
had to turn off her water fountain for
this so jasmine sweetheart
should we do you want your water back
hang on
let's unplug the light
you were thirsty baby
yes today's the fourth of april a sunday
uh it's easter sunday actually
i've been going through the dirac so
basically refreshing
my dirac formulation of standard if you
like quantum mechanics
uh i'm gonna go through the first couple
of chapters in total of this book not
the whole thing
gotta say so far i've been really
enjoying doing this i honestly forgot
how much i enjoyed just sitting down
with a textbook taking notes and
improving my understanding on a subject
you don't get to do it when you're not a
student very much if at all
and i've really enjoyed this opportunity
to just sit down and spend time
quietly learning when learning any
physical theory the first question you
have to ask is
why why do i have to learn this thing
quantum mechanics came into existence
because it was found that classical
physics as derived by people like newton
and maxwell
simply did not work at small scales when
you're talking about
atoms and subatomic particles quantum
field theory came into existence because
quantum mechanics breaks down
when you're looking at very small
objects traveling at great
energies so for example if you
accelerate an electron to huge speeds
that electron can spontaneously produce
pairs of new particles electrons and
positrons for example
and that's something that simply can't
be represented by a wave function in
quantum mechanics you need new physics
to describe that that's where qft comes
in at this point in my studies i've
basically got that
why question i think nailed down in my
initial notes from the z textbook
and now there's a very small matter of
how
we address that need in physics to meld
high energy and quantum mechanics
i'm sure i'm sure this will be easy okay
obviously it's not going to be easy but
the time that i've spent this month so
far revising quantum mechanics and also
getting an appreciation for why this
thing exists in the first place i think
it's put me in a really good position to
really get my teeth stuck into
the maths of how
you mathematically represent objects in
a field theory in a quantum
field theory in fact i'm about to do
that right now on a stream
just as a brief aside i now stream most
days on twitch.tv
for simon clark sometimes i'm playing
games sometimes i'm painting warhammer
a lot of the time i'm actually just
working with a pomodoro timer in the
corner and some chill music and you'd be
very welcome to join and do some work of
your own now
get ready for a bit of a time jump
okay so it is may 17th and
this project has been batted around like
a tennis ball
since our last vlog for this project we
have agreed to
move house i've had the next round of
edits back for the book
and i've written a huge video about star
trek which has taken up all of my time
so the original plan of getting this
done in a month is kind of out the
window i'm now letting this stretch to
the end of
this month and i've got to say i
actually really enjoying stretching this
out because it means i get to spend more
time with the subject matter
and i've been really enjoying actually
understanding this stuff and
appreciating the mathematical beauty and
appreciating it in a way that i just
didn't before when i studied this as
part of my masters
but with that said i do happen to still
have those notes from my masters and i
thought it might be interesting and
potentially traumatic to look through
them and see how i was looking at this
subject what nearly 10 years ago let's
have a look
so it's more organized i remember it
being
tip number 321 don't be a chicken just
take a deep breath and jump
also simon clark is super cool sc is sc
i didn't write that i'm pretty sure that
that was a girl that i used to study
with
who wrote that who i in retrospect
really missed some very obvious signs
right okay so at the back here is all of
the
um lecture notes which i didn't know i
had really useful resource for this
project that's actually amazingly useful
but also in front i have
i have notes from the main lecture notes
obviously
but then i also have notes from
michio kaku i have notes from the z
textbook which i've been taking
notes about i recognize some of these
diagrams and also
is that julia yerman's but i was
actually
taking notes from multiple places which
i don't remember doing i just remember
like
trying to um wrote
learn a lot of this stuff this is
bringing back some
some memories of being in the dingy full
you know bottom level of the library and
trying to make sense of the stuff
here just why and then a date
18th of the of december 2012 why
i think in my head i'd actually worked
this out to be like i was
not working which i was i think
i was working at the time and i was
clearly obsessed with trying to make
this as neat as possible and make it
look like i knew what i was doing
because
at first glance these look like the
notes of a man who knows what he's doing
i know from the time that i wasn't i was
i was really
in a in a bad way i was closer than i
thought to actually doing well at this i
think
my my brain just wasn't accepting this
information
yeah i don't know how i feel about this
i really don't
that's not what i was expecting at this
point i think it's time to talk just a
little more about how quantum field
theory works like how it actually looks
on the page and there are two very
commonly used
different but equivalent approaches in
fact one of the main difficulties with
quantum field theory is disentangling
the many different approaches to the
subject that you find in the literature
but fortunately i knew just the guy to
help me understand
these two different but equivalent
approaches
um so i'm thomas i'm a first year detail
student at the university of oxford
uh specifically at baylier college and
i'm working on
string phenomenology which is trying to
relate uh string theory to particle
physics and cosmology so in quantum
mechanics you have these
uh commutators for people who might not
have studied quantum before
what does a commutator correspond to
physically if you can even answer that
so i think it's easy to see what it
corresponds to if
that is equal to zero if it turns out
they don't commute
uh then it turns out you can measure
these two things at the same time so in
the case of
uh position of momentum because that
commentator is equal to i you may have
heard these things before about how the
more you know someone's position the
less you know it's momentum and that's
kind of a consequence of the fact that
they
uh they don't commute so what you're
doing quantization is you take the same
kind of commutator aspect
and so you take your field which you can
kind of treat as being kind of like
position
and you take your momentum but so a
momentum of the field
there's field momentum so it's a weird
idea and you take the commutator of both
of them you impose that equal to i
times some other funky stuff but this
basically is a direct analogy to what we
already know from quantum mechanics
and that's the kind of canonical
quantization approach the path integral
approach is
entirely different so in the
pathological approach what you do is you
actually just take
your well-behaved and normal classical
physics
you exponentiate it there's something
called the action as well which is
related to
uh to anything in kind of classical
physics you see quite often and that's
all classical physics everything there
and then outside that you then have the
path integral and the path integral then
contains everything quantum so it's this
nice kind of separation if you have
entirely classic or entirely quantum
separating each other and what this
path integral does is it gives a number
to each
possible field configuration is what it
is so if the fields it could be i don't
know it could be all different shapes
the field could be at any one time and
you give a different number to every
single possible one
uh it's easy to see in in a quantum
mechanics when you apply the same idea
where instead of a field configuration
it's then all possible paths between
some initial point and some final point
that a particle will take and similarly
then in
field theory it's given this initial
starting point
and some fight up some other final
configuration kind of
all ways you can map between these two
uh these two ideas
and then you weight them all in some
particular way and then by summing all
of those up you then have
these uh you then get the full unfilled
thing
so it's not obvious at all these two
things are related but both
both work so at this point in the
project this is where my head is at
i've been following the path integral
approach as introduced in the z
textbook the quantum field theory in a
nutshell and following a really useful
conversation with thomas
and looking at mild notes i'm starting
to understand
how you arrive at the same theory the
same equations
from those two completely different
approaches but that's only part of the
story
because going through my old notes also
showed me that my
perception of how i studied this subject
in my fourth year has been
wrong all this time i thought that i'd
failed in my fourth year because
i wasn't smart enough to understand this
subject it was just beyond my
abilities or perhaps that i wasn't
working in the right way
but those notes show me doing all the
right things
drawing from lots of different sources
questioning when i didn't understand
things taking the time to sit with the
subject
what's apparent from learning the
subject now
is what i was missing then
and that was what led me to my failure
all right so i'm in the new house it may
look very similar to the old house but
that's because
well i mean it's the same stuff after
the house move kind of settled down and
we actually got all the big stuff in
place
for the past week or so now i've been
making a consistent effort with going
through
the z and i feel like actually taking a
little bit of time away and letting it
stew in my head
has improved my understanding quite
significantly because i now
looking back through the textbook and
the notes that i've made which is like
just the condensed version of the
textbook
stuff is making a lot more sense
mathematically i'm not as advanced as i
was back then
but conceptually i feel like doing the
phd and studying an advanced field for
as long as i have now has made it easier
to make these conceptual links
and i feel like that part of my brain
and that part of being a student is
stronger now
than it ever was eventually i decided
that i had to finish this project so i
could make
this video so went in hard on a last
week or so of studying it ended up
looking suspiciously like my studying as
an undergraduate
working after i'd finished video work
past midnight
just sustained by this desire to reach
the next conceptual breakthrough
and in the end i felt like i really had
a handle on how this theory and in
particular the path integral version
worked and that brings us to
today so i wanted to give you an example
of how you practically use qft like kind
of what it looks like on the page
let's say that we want to describe two
particles so we have
uh a particle might be an electron it
might be anything for a we know
and another one over here and let's say
that as we go up through the page that's
increasing time
so time let's just say we want to
describe these two particles
propagating up from one point in time to
another point in time
and we could label these if we wanted
but i'm not gonna bother in order to
describe this we define
a field a quantum field which is phi and
we
specifically define an object called a
partition function which
is basically a way of just summarizing
all the information we know about the
system into one
object and specifically we can write it
as a
path integral which i probably haven't
left myself enough room for well done
simon something
a bit like uh this and j here
specifically is describing
uh like the sources and sinks of
particles which we could put at
minus infinity and plus infinity but
it's basically like saying this is
saying that something comes out the
field for a bit and then also disappears
back in the field for a bit the only
problem with this is that this picture
is really boring because we just have
two particles that exist
go forwards in time and then stop
existing
not a great story so what we can do
instead is if i draw a new diagram next
slide please now let's say that these
particles instead of just going a
straight line from their beginning to
their end they actually interact in some
way like they meet
at what we call a vertex this would be
like for example two electrons colliding
i don't know something like that we
could describe the strength of this
interaction
with a number we normally use the greek
letter lambda for that now in order to
represent this interaction taking place
we need to add an extra term up here
because this lambda letter doesn't
appear anywhere up here
and we typically do that because it's
the simplest way of doing this by
writing something
like one over four factorial
lambda and then the fourth power of the
field
now practically solving this is pretty
much impossible so what you can do
is define the exponent here as two
different terms
and separating them out like this this
term here is basically
the propagation term so this is the
uh going from one point to another point
kind of term
and this term is the actual interaction
the strength of the interaction that
takes place here
and what you can do is specify in this
term because it's just an exponent and
one definition of an exponent
is that it's equal to an expansion like
this
and by expanding up to a certain number
of terms your base can basically specify
the number of particles that you're
dealing with and so when you reach
four you can we stop and that's
describing this situation
in fact the way that these two
expansions uh combine
with one another because you've got a
derivative term here and it's acting on
the js that are in this term here
you actually only end up with certain
surviving terms
that then define what interactions are
possible and
those possible interactions are codified
in a set of diagrams that you may have
learned in school
called feynman diagrams obviously this
is a very basic example you've just got
two particles
existing interacting and then stopping
their existence
and yet this is still horrendously
mathematically complicated
so you might wonder well okay this is a
simple example that's lots of maths but
how do researchers actually use this
stuff what is the practical use of this
theory
well i asked thomas what he researched
what i end up using quantum field theory
a lot for
is if you look at string theory you have
these vibrating strings and each one
describe a different type of particle
but what you can do is if you kind of
zoom out enough
then they start to look like particles
and in particular
there's an infinite number of particles
in each different string theory and if
you just take the massless ones
you end up finding that you can find a
corresponding field theory that
describes the same
interactions of particles uh as
described by the string theorem
and so this exists in ten dimensions uh
and to try and relate it back down to
kind of four dimensional particle
physics and cosmology you have to try
and
hide away these additional dimensions by
kind of wrapping them up in some
small place but this is all done in the
context of um field theory you actually
kind of
almost ignore the string theory part of
it you kind of just say this is this is
the
this is the theory that comes out of my
string theory and it's then yeah the
string theory is a black box and you
just take that ten dimensional theory
and then work with that from that point
onwards
so after three months of on and off
studying this subject
what have i learned well i've definitely
learned a lot about quantum field theory
and i feel like i can look at
expressions like these and
actually understand what they're saying
that doesn't intimidate me anymore i
feel like in particular the path
integral approach
makes sense to me now and i have a way
stronger conceptual grasp on it than i
ever did before
but in a way that stuff is the least
interesting stuff that i learned during
this
experience i came away with a whole
bunch of lessons that i
wasn't expecting to learn firstly it
taught me just how much of a privilege
it is to be
a student learning over the past couple
of months
has reminded me just how much i love
learning how much joy there is to be
taken in
sitting down with a good book and a
notepad and improving your own
understanding
slowly feeding your own brain and
over the past three months i would have
loved to have done that all the time
but life got in the way i had to
move house i had to make videos i had to
earn a living
and when you're a student at university
so many of those distractions are
removed and you are able if you want to
just sit in her library
and improve yourself and i feel like i
appreciated it at the time
but not as much as i should have done
this experience taught me just how
valuable your time as a student is
in fact if you are a student watching
this i have a couple of extra takeaways
specifically for you
first of all don't be afraid to use lots
of different resources when pulling
together
your own notes your own understanding i
probably used about a dozen different
sources whether that's lecture notes or
textbooks or online resources whatever
it may be
to help me understand this stuff now and
that made a huge difference
secondly use notion i really enjoyed
using it in this experience for notes
specifically
it's free for students it's super easy
to use hard recommend and
thirdly and something you've probably
already heard before don't be afraid to
ask for help
if you don't understand something and
that doesn't have to be a teacher or a
lecturer or professor
which is probably where your mind
initially went it can be appear if
somebody
one of your friends happens to
understand a subject better than you
perhaps they might be a little bit older
than you
then don't be afraid to ask them for
help it can be a very casual chat like i
had with thomas in this video
if you can join a study group and if one
doesn't exist maybe form one yourself
that's something actually i tried to do
in my fourth year but that uh that kind
of failed to happen
my experience in fourth year at oxford
was the reason why i wanted to do this
project and
i think perhaps i came into it wanting
to forgive my past self but
even to show that i'd grown as an
individual i was smarter now that i
could do this and back then
that guy couldn't but over the course of
this project and
in particular i think through looking at
my old lecture notes i came to realize
that my failure in fourth year wasn't a
failure in intellectual ability
or a failure in effort but it was a
failure
to have something that i've only very
gradually acquired i think over my adult
life since then
and that's self-compassion when i look
through this old footage and read
through my old notes
i see a man who is desperate to
understand something desperate
to prove himself equal to this
incredible
task and is doing all of the things that
in the past had worked incredibly well
to help him understand the stuff
but in this circumstance they weren't
working
stuff wasn't going into his brain and he
took this to be
a failure on his part at that time
something he was doing at that time must
be wrong he wasn't good enough he wasn't
equal to this task
and that led to this negative feedback
this thought spiral that eventually
completely unraveled and looking back on
it now i can see
that there are other factors going on
that man didn't understand some of the
fundamental prerequisites to quantum
theory theory some of the maths
well enough it was like asking a person
to put a brick on top of a house of
cards
the foundations just weren't strong
enough to support this immense
weight but the problem the problem that
made me not understand this stuff in
fourth year i think was fundamentally
one of mindset
when i made a mistake in fourth year i
had this
message in my head that i'm not good
enough i can't understand this i'm not
smart enough you're never gonna be able
to understand this
and then when you go down to problem two
on the problem sheet
that just gets worse and you end up in
this horrible horrible
spiral but when i came at this project
this time
i came at it with a very different
mindset i came at it with this growth
mindset of okay you don't understand
this stuff right now and you just tried
it and you got it wrong
that's okay let's take a bit of time
away go do something else come back to
it
if you still get it wrong then it's time
to ask for help which could be googling
or it could be asking somebody who
really knows what they're doing like
thomas the key to that approach though
is letting your superego take a backseat
and being compassionate towards yourself
compassionate towards your failures
and that attitude that mindset
made such a difference this time i think
that coming into this project i was
seeking to
vanquish the demon of this textbook on
my shelf
and in fact what i did was vanquish this
demon that was still
clinging onto its pages of that negative
mindset and showing me the value
of compassion
undertaking this project was one of the
most rewarding things i've ever
done it taught me a lot about really
interesting physics
but more importantly it taught me about
how important it is to have the right
mindset in learning
and i think it made me finally okay
with what happened in my fourth year so
thank you to my youtube audience for
giving me the opportunity to do this for
giving me the opportunity
to grow
the calculation i showed in this video
was rather simple really a baby problem
if you'd like to see a more advanced
calculation getting my hands dirty in
the guts of quantum field theory then i
have a video showing the derivation of
the electric potential between two
charges and hence
why like electric charges repel over on
my nebula page
nebula as you may have already heard is
the streaming service owned and operated
by a collection of educational youtubers
here we upload content that might not
work
on youtube whether that's because it's
experimental or likely to be suppressed
by the algorithm
as well as releasing our videos early
and without any adverts at all
that's right youtube but with no adverts
not even in the videos themselves
instead our website operates on a
subscription model
you can get a subscription and support
all of these creators
including me by signing up with our
partners curiosity stream
while nebula is all about small indie
creators curiosity stream is about the
biggest
and best documentaries on the internet
like for example
exploring quantum history with brian
greene in this series the famous
physicist traces the origins of quantum
theory
from newtonian physics right up to field
theories
but that's not all they have
documentaries on subjects from
bioluminescence to origami to
this specific bus yes really
so by signing up at curiositystream.com
forward slash simon clark
you get the best of both worlds
individual thoughtful content from
creators like
wendover productions and like stories of
old and big budget
high production value documentaries like
light on earth and exploring quantum
history and best of all by signing up at
the link in the description you get a
whopping
26 off 14.79 a year
or just over 1.20 a month
that's curiositystream.com simon clark
linked below
to get all of this and support creative
ad-free educational content on the
internet
thanks to curiositystream for sponsoring
this video and for partnering up
with nebula thank you so much for
watching this video all the way to the
end
this project was a roller coaster that i
guess actually hasn't really ended
like i quite like to carry on learning
this stuff in my spare time in evenings
when i have
an hour or two maybe opening the
textbook and just seeing how much more i
can understand
but i had to make the video at some
point if you did enjoy the video then
please do pop it a like and let me know
what you thought down there in the
comments
this was more personal than the normal
kinds of videos that i do so i hope you
enjoyed it
and if this struck a chord with you
perhaps you saw some of yourself in my
own
journey here then let me know if you
feel comfortable doing so
about that down in the comments as well
here's some recommended viewing next
thank you again so much for watching and
i will see you in
the next one